there's a lot of that in the new cringe
we got Cody dry-heaving
that's the closest I've ever gotten to
like feelings ill Sam
that was crazy yeah that was actually
that was [ __ ] gross there shouldn't
be a cringe it should be this is [ __ ]
gross yeah I mean maybe that's what I'll
call it we'll see yeah we'll see but
Newt should be out tomorrow hopefully oh
damn and I asked boy I think maybe on
the main channel fast boy Inc yeah I
said it's a main yeah yeah yeah I think
it might be first four minutes really
funny so Wilson main it ain't it ain't
it ain't it ain't cole slaw man yeah
it's the chick it's a it's a chicken
breast yeah I think I will see this is
the first one that I didn't haven't
edited myself
so we'll see shout out to our boy Noah
Noah who's injecting a lot of humor in
in the in the edit it's really [ __ ]
funny and it's like really refreshing
seeing someone else's work who is very
very good better a better editor than me
for sure like it feels good filming a
cringe and then watching it for the
first time yeah cousin I actually get
like some real perspective on whether
it's funny or anything yeah and it also
like it motivates like it's just like I
don't know now that I had to have this
editing work well I'm not saying I'm
gonna not edit all my videos from now on
but I'm gonna offload some of it and
it's just like a good feeling that now
like yesterday I made this song for a
new video and I wouldn't have been able
to do that if I had to edit this video
so now I got another one lined up for
next week yeah already well the other
thing I don't think it's necessarily bad
to offload to editor if if like your
hand picking that editor you know and if
like they understand what you do and
it's not like a job to them then I think
it's fine and when you're too close to
something you can't like you just don't
view it differently yeah you know like I
like whatever like like Sookie like I'm
wrapping it up and I like I'm happy with
the way I cut it but whatever big
project I would do next like I won't cut
it because or I might cut it depending
but I know that editors that just it's a
craft and the more that they do it
they're gonna see things that
I would just never see ya you know and
and it's actually kind of interesting
because some directors big [ __ ]
directors they cut everything yeah which
is like cool but when you look at when
you look at editors who are like known
for just being editors and you see the
way like they cut scenes and stuff you
it has that same effect we were like oh
[ __ ] like one it gives you perspective
as far as like making it but to like
they see things that you don't see yeah
like some of those things that he did
like we would've never yeah yeah and I
just think it's gonna give me it's gonna
give me the confidence I need to really
post more videos because yeah I lose a
lot of enthusiasm and confidence in in
the fact that we're like sometimes I
have an idea but it's not great mm-hmm
and I'm just like I won't film it
because I know like I'm gonna have to
spend hours and hours injecting humor in
the edit right but now if I know oh I
can trust this person to do a great job
yeah
I'm gonna film this thing anyways
because even if it's not a hundred
percent if you know even if I don't feel
fantastic about it there's not that
overarching oh [ __ ] you're also gonna
have to edit this and that's gonna be a
huge huge task to make it funny let's
stop me from doing a lot of [ __ ] like
like early in YouTube that I I really
got turned like sort of like into this
idea with like the twitch stuff because
when you know I was like okay I just
won't cut it and like having that
workflow and like seeing what he would
do back shut out Keo is just like okay
the one thing I always say is I don't
think it's actually so much injecting
humor I think it's actually someone
taking my moments that you don't think
are funny yeah and are funny yeah true
you know very true kyo did that in a lot
of cuts where i'd watch it back and i
and there were parts where I go oh I
didn't even know I said that yeah we're
like I would or like he used it in a way
that was like he punched it at a certain
moment it's like oh wow that was
actually really funny stuff that I would
have just cut yeah yeah yeah but it's
always like that so I think you know
finally know has been great I mean like
I love what he did on [ __ ] steamy
tweets like he me it was a little bit
chaotic but I was into it and yeah some
people were feeling it but I'd like that
yeah
it was great I think I'm just gonna
handpick like what I at it I'm still
gonna edit stuff because I still really
enjoy it mm-hmm and I still I do find it
like a really fulfilling like creative
thing mm-hmm but I think now I'm just
gonna like hand pick and choose and and
anytime I feel a little bit overwhelmed
it's just like okay well yeah let's it
offload this for right now and so I can
focus on like the the creation aspect of
the idea generation phase about making
you know making sure the videos are like
filled out and better with music and
with everything anything else so I don't
know ya know hundred percent I think
it's a I think all-around it's just a
good it'll enable what like it enables
you to be funnier because you are
focused on the creative process and when
you watch stuff back you're watching the
Edit but you're also watching like I
think you can pay more attention to like
how like you're delivering jokes like
kind of like whatever and it's just like
watching film like or like just replays
like okay I could've did this money or
it just gives you ideas about yourself
and editing is can be super taxing so
yeah I think removing yourself is good
yeah hopefully it'll yeah we'll see if
it helps [ __ ] anxiety and [ __ ] like
that - yeah see
I mean it's helped me a ton yeah I mean
I I haven't outside of music videos and
Sukie like I haven't I haven't cut
anything for YouTube in a little while
yeah just it's - over it I had the same
thing like cutting loved Island like I
did a few and like the anxiety I felt
from having to watch that much of me I
don't it was just a weird like I
couldn't do it yeah I don't know it's a
I don't know so it's a I should be able
to write yeah I I relate to you a
thousand percent in that regard we'll
see we'll see anyway how it works
speaking of it's also it's something
that 80% of people don't even [ __ ]
notice oh yeah yeah like all the
comments on your video are like wow
can't believe Noel edited the
description like edited by tomorrow I
don't know she the video that wave pool
yeah how sick was that yeah I mean like
if we're talking on the same one right
yeah yeah sick was that that be
got annihilated hilarious dude I mean
yeah it was huge why does it even go
that high I don't know it's so funny and
the reason is so good dude got drunk and
just set it to 10 what the [ __ ] I
haven't been in a wave pool and forever
there was one name I grew up bro that
was yeah that was not a wave pool that
was crazy
why have we did ever need to go that
side it'd be fun if there was no one
else in there what what the [ __ ] were
they thinking so um we wanna you know
we'd like it to be able to potentially
hurt a lot of people know that we'd like
to simulate destruction if that's
possible like a small-scale tsunami
nothing yeah so what we're gonna do is
the the actual knob is gonna go up to 8
but then we're gonna have an Austin that
with a plastic case over it yeah and G
so you need to open it and press the
thing but don't do it yeah definitely
don't do it yeah and for you know what
15-20 years no one did it no one did it
and then one guy comes in to work a
little bit sauce you know off the white
claw a little bit maybe and he walks in
there and hits that goddamn button ok so
imagine that it's not even a like
restricted like that I like to imagine
it's just like yeah it's good don't put
it on 9 yeah it's got a little tape
marker yeah just let some permanent
markers I don't like big wave yeah
nondescript 4 yeah what what does that
mean ok hey should we do big wave today
no one's ever done it man
I'm [ __ ] down
[Music]
then just send they're wasted like oh
[ __ ]
people got launched yeah dude I just
smoked into the into the bottom they
must have it was huge and they're all on
tubes and [ __ ] like I picked up and just
slam I love how the video starts - it's
just like right as the wave is coming
over and you can see all the people's
reactions that are about to hit it and
they're all kind of like oh this is
supposed to be happening and they see a
[ __ ] the dude like runs away and you
see like the water like Washington blows
feet and he pulls the camera back and
there's just people on their sides it's
just like the whole wave is just picking
up people and so just this papal wave
it's so good so [ __ ] I'm gonna pretend
like I'm even super I mean I'm
empathetic but god damn it it was so
funny we don't know if anyone actually
got a guy said people got injured yeah
but was it what's that like a boo-boo
yeah I don't know you got a boo-boo or
something
[Music]